later date I don't know but
theoretically he caused a lot of harm to
the white supremacist movement so that
I'm glad I think a lot of people were
just mouthing things and not really
thinking about the consequences of what
could happen so this sends a louder
clearer message that you don't have a
lack of consequences you have some
pretty serious consequences and frankly
probably one of the reasons he's not
facing the death penalty is cuz he pled
out I don't know yet I might be able to
sleep tonight I didn't sleep much last
night knowing that he won't be out again
to cause more harm to more people helps
knowing that a clear message has been
sent
hoping to prevent other deaths that
helps other than that I'm kind of done
with him and I'm moving on with my my
life I have things to do no it did I did
the same thing in the state sentencing
he's not listening he's he's trying to
block us so he doesn't have to deal with
any other right now hopefully later some
of that will come back to him anything
else thank you guys thank you for the
work you do free press is essential to a
democracy thank you